في اوائل القرن العشرين انتشرت الفاشيه في
اوروبا كحركه وطنيه يمينيه متعصبه تحتقر
الديمقراطيه تؤمن بالسطو والعنف والحرب
على الامم الاخرى للوصول الى بعث وطني
جديد ولها نجم ساطع في ايطاليا هو الدوتشي
بينيتو موسوليني كان قائدا كاريزماتي
متسلطا حوله الالاف من الشبيحه والزعران
يسبحون بحمده يمجدون عصره ويمجدون جبروته
صباح مساء هتلر الذي هو هتلر هذا هذا كان
من المعجبين بموس ليني فقبل استلامه الحكم
كان يبعث له بالرسائل
يامل ان تصله يطلب منه صوره موقعه لكن
الاخير
يطنش هو الذي الهمه في فكره النازيه حتى
انه طبق نفس التحيه الفاشيه
تعلمون اين اودت هذه الفاشيه بايطاليا
وكيف كانت نهايه زعيمها منذ ذلك الحين
اصبحت الفاشيه حركه منبوذه في البلاد بل
ومجرم قانونا اي ترويج للفاش او رموزها
يعاقب بالسجن لمده قد تصل 12 عاما فاليوم
ايطاليا دوله ديمقراطيه غربيه تقوم على
مبادئ الحريه والليبراليه وتحتك الى دستور
حضاري وتراس حكومتها سيده اسمها جيورج
ميلوني وقد وصلت بانتخابات ديمقراطيه
نزيهه شفافه الفاشيه باي باي لكن قبل ايام
انتشر فيديو لمئات الاشخاص يرتدون الاسود
يؤدون التحيه الفاشيه في ايطاليا بشكل
جماعي خلال حفل تابين في روما
نتابعو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا المقطع كان ل حركه طلابيه تجمعت
لاحياء الذكرى السنويه لرحيل ثلاثه شطاء
يمنيين من حركه تدعى جبهه الشباب وشكلها
اعضاء سابقون في الحزب الفاشي في عام
1978 كان هناك تعليقات كثيره على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي من قبل الايطاليين
وهناك هجوم على حكومه
ميلوني لوتارو يقول اشياء غريبه تحدث الان
في ايطاليا كلمه موسوليني التي كانت قبل
محرمه اصلا تذكر الشخص اصبح ترند على
تويتر الكثير من الايطاليين يحبون
موسيليني ولكنهم لا يقولون ذلك علنا
شاردين يا تقول لماذا لا ارى الشرطه وقوات
التدخل يرتدون معداد مكافحته الشغب لتحييد
هؤلاء الناس الترويج للفاش جريمه ما زانتي
مازانت تقول هذه ايطاليا العظيمه بلدنا
ويحق لنا ان نقوم بما نريد هذه تحيه
رومانيه لا اكثر لماذا اعتبرتم فيديو
مخيفا
جينجي الحكومه الايطاليه تعرف بوجود هؤلاء
الاشخاص لماذا لا تعاقبهم بتهم الضرر
بالامن العام هذا المقطع مؤشر خطير على ما
يمكن ان يحدثه هؤلاء في ايطاليا لماذا
ستعاقب ما رئيسه الحكومه جورجيا
ميلوني هي نفسها كانت عضوه في جبهه الشباب
حتى حزبها الحالي تعود جذوره الى المجموعه
نفسها رفضت ميلوني تعليق مباشره على الحدث
ووصفت ردود الفعل بانها هجمات غير مبرره
على حكومتها عموما المحكمه العليا في
ايطاليا قررت ان اداء التحيه الفاشيه في
المسيرات امر قانوني تقول التحيه
الرومانيه لا تعتبر جريمه الا اذا كان
هناك خطر ملموس من اعاده تاسيس الحزب
الفاشي او كانت هناك اهداف ملموسه للتمييز
العنصري والعنف